alors allez capitaine six crêtes de tour de guet
tombent de loin sur la terre comme
un seau réduit Jack salut
ou pas Jack tu vas
m'aider je vais briser la malédiction de mon père je
vais savoir viens maintenant beaucoup tu saisis mon
carré le pommeau beaucoup mieux  maintenant
et assurez-vous que votre premier meurtre
heureux d'être un partenaire ne vous dérange pas
tout le sang et les globes oculaires exorbités
et peut-être que je ne suis pas les pirates mais
vous avez tort si vous pensez que je ne le ferais
pas et vous  ont tort s'il est en livraison la
prochaine fois que vous soulevez un massacre, je suis sûr que
la poursuite avec les requins go où
ils poursuivent la chaloupe
nous en avons tiré une partie à un endroit où
nous ajoutions l'île à l'
arrière-plan alors nous avions  un petit
emplacement de réservoir d'eau avec une barque sur un cardan
pour une interaction directe avec les gens et l'
eau, nous avons ensuite créé un autre environnement
où nous avons tourné sur une scène à écran bleu et
un intérieur, donc dans cette séquence, vous
pourriez couper d'un emplacement à un
réservoir  tourné vers un écran bleu dans un
cache  r de quelques secondes et notre travail consistait
à essayer de nous assurer que nous
créions l'eau cg et les extensions océaniques VCG
autour d'elle pour correspondre
suffisamment bien à l'emplacement de l'action réelle pour qu'une
plante que
nous ayons en quelque sorte le meilleur des deux mondes
nous  avoir la partie numérique à portée de main et
nous avons les trucs pratiques qui ont été
tournés et mis en place dans chacun de ces plans de
petites manières une combinaison cela dépend de
ce qui fonctionne le mieux
[Musique]
quel était votre tissu de scène préféré ouais
j'ai vraiment aimé le truc  à la fin
quand nous sommes dans les Pentecôtes parce que
ça avait été un tournage si difficile et si
long et tout le monde était si fatigué, puis nous avons
tous pris un vol et nous nous sommes
retrouvés sur cette petite île paradisiaque et c'était
comme si nous  étaient en vacances en
famille ouais et la scène finale que nous avons tournée
était nous courant sur cette plage au
coucher du soleil avec Johnny et Jeffrey et tous
les pirates et je me souviens avoir pensé que
c'était une si bonne façon de le terminer si
cela avait été le  première semaine alors nous
aurions j  Nous étions épuisés à la
fin, mais pour avoir ce genre d'ascenseur et d'
esprit à la fin, je me souviens que nous
avions une scène où nous ne pouvions le faire qu'une
fois que vous savez courir sur la plage après
que la plage a été détruite et qu'ils
ne pouvaient pas réinitialiser  Je me souviens avoir pensé à
une façon fantastique de terminer un film,
vous savez en une seule prise, nous pensons comme
ça, vous savez, après cela, nous ne
pouvons plus recommencer en
perdant la ligne d'arrivée en courant vers
la ligne d'arrivée
les cheveux comme je l'ai dit  J'en ai vu quelques
dessins mais je n'avais pas la moindre idée de ce à quoi
je ressemblerais réellement à l'écran, donc vous
devez avoir un acte de foi pour dire d'accord
et j'aime cette idée parce que c'est comme un
esprit flottant comme mais aussi m'a tenu à
pour apporter plus d'épaisseur dans le
comportement du personnage sachant qu'il
y a quelque chose de plus léger dans le
look sous-marin pour les fantômes, il s'agissait en
quelque sorte de vraiment vendre ce
sentiment que ces personnages étaient
sous l'eau même s'ils n'étaient
pas réellement sous l'eau en termes de
quoi  Avant qu'ils ne soient dans l'espace, il y avait donc
quelques choses qui ont été faites principalement en
relation avec les cheveux dans le tissu en
termes de mouvement et de flux
enos et en s'assurant que nous
trouvions le bon équilibre de mouvement
qui était flottant mais  ne pas se sentir mal à l'aise
ou étrange et je pense que nous avons
trouvé un bon équilibre avec lui dans les
effets visuels, l'une des choses les plus importantes
pour nous de pouvoir donner aux réalisateurs
était la possibilité de pouvoir
composer et réduire la performance  des
cheveux dans le tissu et de la façon dont ils
flottaient, ce que nous avons trouvé très rapidement,
c'est que lorsque vous avez un acteur
comme Javier qui donne
une performance aussi incroyablement forte, la dernière
chose que vous voulez faire est de marcher dessus de
quelque manière que ce soit, donc  Je dirais que le plus souvent, ils
finissent par composer à l'
extrême les extrémités du mouvement
des parties flottantes de leur corps,
le tissu, les blessures et les cheveux
afin de ne rien enlever au
visage du pe  performances